i need to fix your faces we got cb3 in
arizona y'all trippin
we got chris paul in phoenix
chris all right
fix y'all faces we got vinnie goodwill
our third brother from another what's
going on man how you doing
i'm good man i'm i'm uh enjoying the day
how y'all doing
no competition awesome no complaints
whatsoever uh it's a great shirt man
it is a good shirt it's a good it's a
good shirt day it's been a crazy week in
the nba in particular
um but so we got we got a lot to cover
with you got kyrie news today we got uh
paul george has
said some stuff but we're gonna go back
to the big to the biggest story of the
week which is the john wall
uh russell westbrook trade
you probably so you probably were some
shock when it when it happened because
you know you got your
your ear to the streets on these things
what do you think about the trade in
general when it first happened
you know how you you know you move into
a house and you've
been there for a minute and you just
want to move some stuff around
you just want to move a couch just to
move a chair
it don't really change the aesthetic of
the house it don't change anything
like but you're just moving some stuff
around that's what i feel like the
wizards there was like you know what i
got a problem here
you got a problem here let's just
exchange my problem for your problem
i know that you'll probably make the
solution to my problem and my problem
with the solution of yours
but we just gonna do some moving around
just to say that we did something
like can you tell me that houston is
markedly better or that washington is
markedly better
like i get it but to me it signifies the
fact that
both of these dudes the fact that they
could only be traded for each other
and that's a few teams need the
championship level point guards
and nobody made a call for russell
westbrook
or john wall just to see i mean
milwaukee is desperate right to keep
giannis they're desperate to keep their
star
even if you ain't the fit you go and try
to make a couple calls
same thing with the clippers the
clippers get all types of issues
and they're like you know what we don't
want russell westbrook or john wald over
here we straight
so to me i would think that that's a
signal that neither one of these dudes
are exactly where we think they are
they're just a couple names but you know
what vinnie
uh look washington got the better player
and houston winds up with the better uh
spiritual situation because it seems
like james harden just wanted
that one at westbrook out of there that
something was going on there so
you say it's moving the furniture around
but in this case
just a different personality is what
houston needed so i think it was a
little more significant than you making
it out to be
yeah i don't see how this is changing i
don't see how this changes anything
like okay james harden is still there
let's just say james harden magically
does not want his jersey retired in a
place other than the strip club in
houston and he's just like you know what
cool
i'ma stay here and we just gonna kick it
here all right all right
cool let's just let's just take that for
that face value
you mean to tell me that he's like you
know what trade my boy
russell westbrook after he said you know
what i can't stand chris paul trade him
at some point when is james harden going
to look at and say you know maybe i'm
hard to play with
as opposed to just saying you know what
we're gonna make a real change here
and john wall think about it a guy who
hasn't played in two
full seasons essentially he's played in
maybe 70-something games over the past
two years
we haven't seen him play he's coming off
an achilles and another foot injury
you mean to tell me mike michael holly
that this
is a proactive move on the part of
houston rockets to try to
keep james harden like at some point do
you just stop listening to this dude
because he's taking you all
down all types of bad roads like tell me
how to make this make sense to me
it's funny you said that because
yesterday i joked uh
i called james harden the nba's stop
cause like he's running through
everybody
like i mean he he he going through look
every star
possible which you know to that end and
i and i saw the athletic did a deep dive
on the dysfunction basketball card in
houston
and he did a deep dive on the
dysfunction in houston
athletic did and it talked about how
russell westbrook
felt like he was scapegoated and i can
honestly i find it hard to believe now
while russell does have a reputation
uh from a basketball standpoint in
particular
of being difficult to play with because
he's so ball dominant we know about that
but how if you're in houston and
everything goes through james harden as
an organization
and he's had all these different
co-stars and everybody
saw russell play great basketball and
then come back
from covid and hurt in the bubble rush
back
i find it hard to believe that people
would really try to scapegoat
russell westbrook and make him to blame
for the rockets falling short again it
feels like this whole off season
really has been a referendum on james
harden right vinny
it should be i mean because i think
russell westbrook feels this way for
these reasons if you look at if you
reading the story and understand the way
that that team dynamic when he was
talking about
hey we need to call team meetings to
hold guys accountable and everything
else
and he's trying to do that and imagine
being in a meeting
and you're trying to get everybody on
the same page like imagine we're all
in some warm world of normalcy we can be
in the same room with each other
and you're trying to hold people
accountable and you're trying to do all
these different things and everybody's
looking at you with a blank face
like no we don't do that here we don't
call out james harden and tell him hey
why don't you
move to different parts of the floor why
don't you play better defense why don't
you do these different things
so if you're not getting the response
that you're used to and i'm not saying
that the russell westbrook way
or the russell westbrook culture is the
best culture of the way to do things
because i feel like in oklahoma city
that everything funneled to him and
there wasn't a lot of air for anybody
else on the floor
but for him of all people to say you
know what something's off here
further no further now
[Music]
that's like the the student who's
getting them
in trouble for behavior issues pointing
to another kid and be like man he bad as
hell
can't take him nowhere but wait all
right so
i want to stay in houston though because
to your point about james harden still
wanting to
uh to get up out of dodge and then maybe
go to brooklyn and play with uh
uh kyrie and kd so steven silas had some
interesting comments yesterday i'm sure
you heard him vinny
talk about he giving james harden uh his
space uh i think we got the sound of
that gary let's roll that song from
stephen silas
we'll get there we'll get there we go
steven silas
when stuff like this kind of happens
where there's a little indecision
and stuff going on i kind of take a step
back
and allow guys some some space so
from my perspective my communication has
been
i'm giving you space and that's kind of
where it's been
as far as my um communication with him
and uh you know guys like that need that
they they need to figure it out and they
need to they don't need someone
banging on them all the time to um
kind of figure out where they're at and
and whatnot
respectfully respectfully yeah i don't
understand
but respectfully like say dog like like
you into you out like we grown men here
like i'm not i'm not chasing nobody man
i'm too old for that
like i ain't got time to be trying to
give you your space like we married we
don't go together
like we ain't seeing other people like
you know what i'm saying like yo you
don't get space
when you're under contract and you're
the face of the franchise
vinny i don't michael vinnie i don't see
a middle ground it's like either
you are we are trading you or we're not
trading you but if we're not trading you
you need to have your
ass home at night you know love should
have brought you home last night like
when i got tired of speaking to you like
let me let me give you your space like
space for what to do what to consider
what like
what are we doing here as a perfect
segue from the love [ __ ] of brought you
home he is one step
away from walking for marcus graham
walking through the office
after breaking up with jacqueline and
everybody looking at him sideways like
man you're the sucker cause that's how
he sounds like right now
he sounds like the dude that doesn't
know that he's been broken up with yet
and everybody knows that his business is
on the streets and the thing is
we know nothing about steven silas so
right now he just looks like the mark
when he says man you give somebody some
time
and he started rubbing his chest i'm
like do you got indigestion there
brother you all right you feeling okay
[Music]
imagine being waiting all this time 20
plus
years 50 11 years to get a head coaching
job
and james harden goes off and plays you
for the food in front of
everybody no respect at all like a jay-z
line
you better check a dog yeah yeah hey man
you know i think i think for steven
silas and
the rockets they're in a tough space
because what they want to do
is trade them i'm sure or
or they want to definitely trade them or
definitely keep them but there's no
there's nothing you can do because if
you say we want to trade them
now you've given up all your leverage uh
you definitely keep them
but he's still not listening to you so
you're kind of in a tough space like
publicly that what kind of message are
you sending publicly what i wouldn't say
though if i'm stephen silas is
i'm giving him space because that's my
communication style well
that's bad communication i don't know if
if michael smith and vinnie goodwill you
guys both of you
if you are giving me space and i don't
hear from you
how do i know that you're giving me
space how much am i reading your minds
how do i know that
that is a bad communication technique
well here's the thing
he's not coming in as a guy who was an
assistant with that team
he's walking into a set of circumstances
and ideals that were set long before he
got here so he's walking in
they're saying james harden is in charge
and you're working for tillman for tita
and this is how we deal with things here
with james harden being in charge
you don't have a choice other than to
play and look like the fool
because everybody else has played and
looked like the fool
for james harden james harden wanted
chris paul up out of there chris paul
got up out of there
daryl moy couldn't take it anymore daryl
mori is up out of there same with mike
d'antoni
everything that has been run by that
franchise has been run that way because
james harden wanted it that way
and if you're the new coach and the new
black coach
in there working for tillman fertitta i
need not tell you guys what type of
walking you have to tread on
so that you stay employed beyond let's
say the next three to four months
i wonder if harden uh is upset because
westbrook got his way they if they both
this girl and they want it out
even though he didn't want westbrook
they found a way to get westbrook out of
dodge and harden's like man what about
me i'm trying to go to brooklyn
but you but just before we hit the break
though vinnie real quick i want to
go back to the other side of this trade
there were multiple teams multiple
layers because it's not just
getting john wall and what it means for
james harden's future in houston
it's also you know the better and at
least the healthier player
is russell westbrook flaws gordon to
washington
yeah no no but i'm saying you know he's
better and he's healthier
um no question about it that's why the
first round pick went back
what what do you think this means in the
short term
for washington's potential to be a play
in
if not a potential playoff team in the
eastern
conference with scott brooks and does
bradley beal fit with
russell westbrook so well that beale
sticks around
or is he about to be one and done uh
indeed not one and done but is he about
to be up out of dc after this season
look the washington wizards have been a
part of my life since i started watching
nba basketball they've never won 50
games i don't think they've ever i think
they've won one playoff series
you telling me that the team can't get
right decide if they going to get it
right by bringing in
russell westbrook on a team coach about
scott brooks i need y'all to tell me
what fantasy world we living in where
that is the solution to the problem
for the franchise that has never gotten
it right that will probably never get it
right
all of a sudden getting with the player
that can't get it right and all of a
sudden they'll make it
a little rock that's a good looking
little roster though wait a second i get
wait i know i know we're talking about a
checkered pass to be kind but that's a
good looking little roster though
and here's what they didn't have last
year all of last year
john wall now they at least got a guy
that's going to show up and play
in russell and not that you know john
while blood is achilles but jenna said
i'm saying i said show up and play
they got a guy that's there available
that's the ability is availability they
have they've added russell westbrook
when they didn't have john walls so they
they're better
immediately just by getting westbrook
than they were don't answer i mean they
got some shooters around him
mike then uh i don't know mike we spent
a lot of time this week talking about
all the money that the lakers rightfully
so
uh gave lebron james uh and anthony
davis
a couple of extensions 85 million for
the king 190 over five
for anthony davis some talk coming out
of la
michael holly i don't know if you saw
this uh jared dudley talking about he's
expecting a.d
to make a uh an mvp push this year
lebron ain't trying to not win another
one but what you think about that
uh well this is what i think about it
wasn't he in the mvp convert he should
have been
i know he wasn't it came down to giannis
and lebron
but if you look at anthony davis's
season last year that's the mvp caliber
season
and and the only reason we didn't say
it's because he's playing on the same
team as lebron
but anthony davis has had if you look at
his career i know i've switched on this
i've totally switched on it mike
uh and i own it but if you look at some
of the
accomplishments throughout his career
he's had
mvp seasons before and for them to
get to that point that i talked about
where i said the lakers extend contracts
and windows
if they're going to continue uh the mini
dynasty that i think they can have
and many meaning like two or three
championships
in a four year span something like that
anthony davis will have to be the mvp
for that to happen vinnie do you do can
he win an mvp
with the best player in the world on his
team like you
do you have a vote you have a vote right
vinny don't you have a vote yep i have a
vote
so i mean you tell me you have to mike
you got gotta you gotta show
me a world where lebron james isn't the
driving force on any team
that he's played on and willingly sees
that space
because i remember cleveland he said you
know i'm gonna be handing off a little
bit more to kyrie irving this year i
know we're gonna get to kyrie and some
of his nonsense
in a minute but i don't see a world
where
lebron who has who is as aware
of his place in history aware of
his standing in theater in terms of
basketball theater
i don't see him taking a place where he
willingly
sees that even to someone like anthony
davis i don't think anthony davis has
this dominant personality where he's
going to say
this is now mine and lebron says you
know what you write as yours
but i do agree that for this to happen
there has to be some sort of
magic kareem passing of the torch
to maximize what they have better
because the guy who let them
scoring rebound field goal percentage
three-point shooting
blocks steals and free throw shooting
last year was not lebron james
it was anthony davis so the question is
is anthony davis
already the best player on that team
oh okay oh no you're getting you know
what vinnie getting warmed up
vinny getting warmed up for friday you
know he's just like let me try to
let me just talk to him i know what
you're doing and let me just
okay he is okay he caught look we don't
call him
for nothing we don't think that
microwave for nothing vinnie come out
shooting
vinnie you you you are not a you are not
a bench player
you just don't start you know you just
don't start for brother from another but
you
you're a scorer you got you come out
scoring with these things
um staying in that later man this
clippers drama we talked about it
earlier this week
uh the athletic unloaded on the clippers
and the special treatment the
preferential treatment and that kyrie
excuse me uh kawhi leonard has been
getting uh with that organization and
mike i don't think i said this to you
michael
i had vinnie's voice in my head because
i feel like when they were collapsing
against the nuggets
no i'm serious i feel like whenever
collapsing against nuggets you were on
the show
talking about the lack of leadership on
the floor i
i feel like you spoke to that uh and
then by the way i know if y'all saw this
paul george michael you see this paul
george today said he wants to retire a
clipper
just come on whatever that's worth yeah
but then read that athletic story and
all the dirty laundry
deadlines i trained him at the deadline
it just but really it just kind of feels
like
you know that they don't have a fighting
chance given the chemistry issues
that they had last year and then i don't
know how they would have fixed it this
year just by switching out the coach
well you didn't just switch out the
coach montrez harold isn't there anymore
and depending on who you talk to around
the league
maybe patrick beverly can be had maybe
lou williams can be had
and my thing is kawhi leonard and paul
george receiving special treatment
that like make them bad or anything like
you're going to push the limit as far as
you
can on if somebody tells you you can be
late and you ain't got to practice or
you ain't got to come to work yeah you
play when you want to play
and they say yes then that ain't
necessarily
on you at this point it's incumbent upon
coi to say okay you know what
if i'm going to be the de facto leader
of this team if this is my
organization this is my franchise then i
have to see and be aware of what this
looks like to everybody else
and if that's the case then i have to
put some guardrails
on my own sort of special agreement now
does he have the self-discipline to do
that
i don't i'm not saying i don't i'm not
sure but i don't know who necessarily
does if you give them all that freedom
i think their problem is just they don't
have a point guard and they didn't go
out and
get a point guard and maybe they will at
the trade deadline
but to me i still look at them as being
deep enough and good enough to compete
with the lakers
the problem is the lakers get better and
the problem is you have far more
questions
than answers and look paul george can
want to retire a clipper i thought he
retired in game five of the western
conference center
i don't remember seeing them since oh
grim
shot wait but just i'm gonna jump back
in on one thing though
there's preferential treatment hey
listen this is all report reports
but then there's a stuff about you know
his own locker room space and how to run
people the wrong way even if it meant
that you know
cheerleaders you know weren't able to
use the bathroom or excuse me i should
say female staff weren't able to use the
bathroom
late flights missing practice canceling
practice
you know uh asking in and out of games
or refusing to go into games
that's next level special special
preferential treatment special treatment
excuse me
combined words and i look at not just
doc rivers michael but like i mentioned
that's steve baumer that's
organizational you know they were just
waiting
thirsty to get kawhi leonard there and
paul george ain't earned that kind of
special uh truck
i can't speak today special treatment
treatment i got you yeah but i'm with
you you know what
mike and vinnie uh i and just hearing
all these reports i'm glad you uh
referenced them all mike because it's
just so much of
all these all these little whispers and
innuendo and hey what do you think about
that and people just leave it out there
for you to interpret
i was offended by two things here one
that they went in on our nation's second
black president that would be glenn doc
rivers
and i didn't appreciate that at all
that's my president that's my president
leave him alone
and the other thing is look if you're if
you if you're paul george
and you're kawhi vinnie and you're a
combined
10 for 38 in a game seven
and you're one of one guy is a multiple
finals mvp and the other guy thinks that
he's a he's a great player
i don't want to hear anything you have
to say you were 10 for 38 in game seven
and ain't about or iq and her
accountability
you didn't get the job done and that's a
big reason
why y'all lost to uh uh the the denver
nuggets and blew a 3-1 lead
there's got to be some responsibility
taken by everybody
and i was a person say this i was a
person based off of kawhi's
team playoff run that said kawhilin is
the best player in basketball until
proven otherwise until kevin durant
that i was saying up until that kawhi
leonard was the best player in
basketball because of what he does on
both ends of the floor
he clearly was not as engaged on both
ends of the floor
especially toward the end of that series
he did not he start to look a little bit
on the heavier side like weight wise i
know a lot of that is muscle and
everything else
but i won't say the decline has happened
but that's the first
real if you think about it blemish on
kawhi because that situation with the
spurs
that felt like that was a lot of mystery
that we didn't know about
you know what i mean like there was no
real blame because there was only so
much information that we knew about
this is the first thing that's going to
stick to him a little bit and he's going
to have to i'm going to say redeem
himself because he's a two-time finals
mvp
and he's a made man but this is
something that he's going to have to
rebound from and
organizationally you got to think doc
rivers
is dr rivers and paul george have a bit
of a personal relationship
there and there have not there's been
more than one person
around the nba that has suggested to me
hey
look they're both human you can't tell
me that these things don't play
into it at some point not necessarily
when things are going good or when
things are going bad
but when you have to give a player the
benefit of the doubt
or if a player has to give the coach the
benefit of the doubt
do they lean on that side and what i saw
in the last three games of that series
were players who did not give each other
the benefit of the doubt and the culture
said you know what
i'm done with y'all and not i'm done
with y'all as if i'm giving up on y'all
but y'all have made this bed y'all
figure it out
we've seen coaches do that we've seen
phil jackson do that with the lakers in
in portland
when they were down 17 at game seven and
he said i'll see y'all next summer you
know i'll see you next fall and they
made and they made that turn around
so it's not that doc was watching his
hands of it but at some point they're
all adults out there y'all grown me
y'all
y'all get yourselves into this get
yourselves out of this and there's been
a lack of accountability i felt like
from the beginning there
because because people like me
i said they're going to get it together
when they when they have to
i gave them a certain level of grace
that they hadn't necessarily
earned they had to hand up earned it and
now they get
in that look man look mike i'm sure
you've done it just like i have
sometimes you dared a woman
that was so fine you gave her every
benefit of the doubt you gave her every
excuse
that was possible and then when you saw
in the light you was like you know what
this
this is my fault i and i am an enabler
they were simping they were simping on
the front end when it was firing bruce
was who was it bruce boeing when he was
firing him criticizing before he even
got to kawhi
before he even got that it was simple it
was simple so um
we got to get to uh to kyrie irving man
um
he spoke to him he didn't speak to the
media
he issued a statement uh he went he went
the old-fashioned round
uh he addressed it did not speak to me
he addressed the media yeah one form or
another uh do we have that uh let's uh
let's show you a little bit of of what
he had to say copin 19 has impacted us
all
in many ways so i pray for the safety
and health of our communities
domestically and abroad i am truly
excited for the season to start
and i'm also praying that everyone
remains safe and healthy throughout this
journey
instead of speaking to the media today i
am issuing this statement to ensure that
my message is conveyed properly
uh-oh i am committed to show up and work
every day ready to have fun compete
perform and win championships
alongside my teammates and colleagues in
the nets organization my goal this
season
is to let my work on and off the court
speak for itself
life hit differently this year and it
requires us it requires me
to move differently so this is the
beginning
of that change okay
um all right i i guess i get it
mike vinnie look mike thinks this is
doomed to to
for disaster anyway you are not feeling
this brooklyn experiment to begin with
so
mike start it off what's your how you
probably got it
okay now i reserved the right once what
i said i reserve the right to be stupid
i said that before
i reserve the right to change my mind as
the facts change so in your opinion yeah
but my first reading of the reading like
literal reading of this fellows
is that i understand this is actually
growth from kyrie irving because he has
now what he didn't put in the statement
i'm just going to just read something
into it he has a knack
for saying too much you know like some
people you give them like the notes
saying you're gonna go in front of me
you're gonna say this this and this here
are three points you go ahead and do it
and they go in there and they give you
seven things they tell they say too much
like oh man why'd you do that we talked
about this beforehand
that's what he usually does in this case
he's not letting any of that other stuff
you're not gonna twist me up
i'm gonna say this is what i wanna say
this is all i wanna say
and i'm gonna focus on the season i
think it's actually
good because he's so sensitive and and
durant they're so sensitive
this is the way to do it this is i i
really don't think about
you talking about reading into things so
okay you're reading between the lines
i'm just reading vinnie's face and body
language and i'm amused benny ain't even
saying a word yet
i'm picking up some vibes from vinnie go
ahead ben
then he feels some kind of way about
this better and let's discuss discuss
our workload
just don't work alone
okay if you are a grown man and you
cannot control the statements that you
say
in front of the big bad media across a
zoom
teleconference i don't think kyrie
irving is a bad guy
i think kyrie irving fancies himself to
be a little bit smarter than
what he is and fancies the media to be a
little too simplistic
he puts us in the box when he claims
that we put him
in a box i find that rather amusing so
whether kyrie irving doesn't talk to the
media for the rest of the year
and this is the beginning of that change
and you guys can't twist my words
it wasn't the media that said we don't
need a coach jack bonker can be the
coach one day
i can be the coach one day like that
wasn't the media that said that that was
on a podcast
your words not the quotes not anything
and
for me it's about guys having to take
responsibility
like you are a grown man you were doing
great work he's done great work
as far as what he was doing in terms of
social justice with what he was doing
with the wnba
and we can put all those things together
and say that
kyrie irving is a quality human being
but a lot of times he sticks
his foot in his mouth it's not that he
says too much sometimes he just says
dumb stuff
that is worthy of scrutiny and i don't
think we have to necessarily give him an
excuse
for saying dumb stuff sometimes you
think you are a little
too smart and when people call you out
on it then all of a sudden well y'all
know i didn't mean it like that
y'all just twisted my words you ever had
a friend that was a little too smart
and you'd be like you're a c student be
a c student
like that i'm not saying kyrie's c
student he is a brilliant basketball
player
he has a big heart he thinks completely
different ways but nobody told him to
say
flat nobody told him to say that you
know poop is like the white ball
knocking the black ball off of the face
of the earth you know what i'm saying
like kyrie puts his own doors
that says poor and blames the door that
ain't awful
hey man since you're dropping bars on
the way out uh we were texted earlier we
got to celebrate
uh uh recognize jay-z's birthday uh
is today uh you know
i've been told that you can't have a
credible top five
without jay-z sorry he's not in my
personal top five
but there's no denying what the man
has done and continues to do uh
throughout the industry and the culture
at large so you want to uh give jay-z
some flowers on your way out vinnie
goodwill
can y'all get me some flowers it's my
birthday stay tuned y'all want me to
give them flowers to another grown man
when today when it's my boring day
today oh man bro you wack for that
dawg you waxed for that no wait wait
first of all
okay happy birthday vinnie goodwill i
can't
like that thank you mike i haven't been
burying that lead
like i ain't talking to you today say
dog like
when we talked last week you asked me
and i told you yeah my brother
michael will you tell this dude i can't
remember what people tell me this
morning
that's true that's true
bro i got enough stuff going on in my
head you gotta keep catching them
okay i'm thinking about talking about
reasonable doubt
i thought we about to talk about the
blueprint black album in my lifetime and
and i asked you on tech i said say bro
what else you want to talk about today
he's like it's jay-z's bro
and i'll be like yeah what y'all want to
talk about while i say yeah let's talk
about my birthday on your show like hot
like come on i
i ain't that much gary change into rap
icon
mogul vinnie good birthday cousin vinnie
[Laughter]
but if you want my my top three jay-z
rap albums is reasonable
blueprint black album the first two of
classes the third is
a little bit you know it's got too many
too many thuds
there you go okay but no but i mean you
know
what are you doing i mean we're in a
pandemic what are you doing for your
birthday
man like happy birthday first of all
thank you for blessing the show
giving us the gift of on your birthdays
all right extra time on your birthday
some people i know are spending their
don't want to come on
show i'm not gonna say no no come on
don't wanna come on our show on their
birthday because they busy
i ain't going to go put his business in
the street i can put it i'm just like
okay don't do that but that's amazing
but point b
i know what you're talking about that's
an amazing story the fact that you're
here speaks volumes in this relationship
so what are you what you doing today man
what's going on
but you got points you said it earlier
we're in the middle of a pandemic i feel
like 2020 has been one
long gas 40 degree day
[Laughter]
i'm chilling i might have i might have a
nice a nice beverage either nice red
wine or a nice cognac
you know have a nice dinner and and that
that's kind of that's kind of it
i'm on the clock the nba schedule just
got released kyrie irving just said
something silly
paul george just went paul george on
everybody like you know
i just had to push the vacation back a
little bit i'll you know i'm gonna go to
y'all for
for recommendations because i'm sure
mike them been everywhere from santro
pay to bora bora
so you know
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you